my favorite visual of the week other
than Donald Trump at the omelet station
at his Golf Club is what happened at the
Munich Security Conference when Mike
Pence mentioned Donald Trump and what
happened is complete silence I'm gonna
play a clip for you here where you will
see Mike Pence vice president in Munich
say Lindsey Graham led this delegation
to the Munich Security Conference let's
thank him for that and then you will
hear clapping and then Mike Pence will
say also Donald Trump and then it's
complete and total silence during what
was supposed to be an applause line and
the audio is good enough but if you're
only listening on the radio or on the
podcast find the visual of this because
the visual just shows you the full scope
of it pence sort of looks around he's
not sure I mean he said an applause line
why is no one clapping the reason is
that the mango menace is increasingly an
object of ridicule around the world
let's take a look at the video I
especially want to invite all of you to
thank Senator Lindsey Graham for leading
and today I've got all of the yuan three
ingredients from a great champion of
freedom and the strong national defense
who has worked with these members of
Congress to strengthen America's
military might and to strengthen the
leadership of the free world I bring
greetings from the 45th President of the
United States of America president
Donald Trump oh it is just the best
everyone should be the glad that the
crowd didn't merely laugh at the mention
of Trump's name and what we're seeing
here it's just what's going on around
the world when it comes to world leaders
view of Trump it's mostly who cares
Trump's contributing nothing positive
internationally and I know when we play
this Pat that the committed trumpets
don't care but this is part of that
tenuous and strained relationship
between the US and European allies when
pence shows up and says France Germany
and the UK should pull out of the Iran
nuclear deal because we did world
leaders recognize that if Iran doesn't
violate the deal which they didn't it's
a really bad idea to pull out it makes
the u.s. look bad when they realized
that there's no point in even inviting
the United States Trump administration
to participate in discussions related to
climate change because Trump thinks it's
a hoax this is the point of view of the
rest of the world increasingly which is
it's not even laughing it's just who
cares about Trump part of the reason why
that video is so great it's because Mike
Pence actually looked surprised he's
shocked that people aren't clapping it
shouldn't be a surprise at all I don't
think like he should expect that
European leaders are not going to be on
his side in this one yeah US diplomatic
influence is on the decline US influence
around the world is on the decline were
no longer a part of the climate change
conversation the world knows that on
geopolitics Trump's priorities are
completely backwards he's compromised at
minimum by Vladimir Putin also possibly
by Saudi Arabia on technology on
high-speed trains on all sorts of stuff
we are falling
further and further behind the dollar as
I've been telling you for a year now is
less and less the transactional and
default currency for countries around
the world the world sees Trump pence as
phonies which they are they have no
business being in charge but it's having
a real-world impact and it is an
embarrassment when Trump administration
delegates including up to up to and
including Mike Pence and Donald Trump
themselves it's an embarrassment around
the world in the literal sense the UN
laughs the Munich Security Conference
simply doesn't even react to the
applause line of the great champion of
freedom and security Donald Trump it's
an absolute and total embarrassment